Speaker 1: Speaking of vaccines, there
is something very interesting going on,
which is that Donald Trump, the former
president, although he was softly dismissive of
vaccination when it comes to any kind of
requirement and continued to play up freedom,
we all need our freedom. We all need. Our freedom
has actually become a very forceful advocate
for the safety and efficacy of COVID vaccines,
and we have an incredible clip from yesterday.
Donald Trump did another interview with OANN. So
you've got Fox News, which is crazy right wing.
You've got Newsmax, which is even crazier, and
then you've got OANN, which is even crazier
than Newsmax. And Donald Trump was sort of
softly confronted by the reporter about,
there's all these people concerned. There's all
these concerns about the vaccine. And Donald
Trump very forcefully said it's ridiculous. And
by the way, listen to when Trump says there are
officials who are not even telling the truth
that they've been vaccinated. I believe he
is signaling wrong. Ron DeSantis here, and I'm
going to get back to that. Check out this clip.
Speaker 2: This because a lot of viewers wrote
in, I put a kind of old call out to our viewers
on the program. If you had questions for the
president, what would have been top to election
integrity? We'll get to in a second. But the
other one was the vaccine. Right? You recently
stated the interview with Candace Owens and when
you were on the road with Bill O'Reilly doing
the book tour of the speaking engagement that
you've had the vaccine two shots and you've had
the booster right and you recommend it for
folks. We have seen with the Veirs report,
there's tens of thousands of side effects.
Speaker 1: Now, remember, the Veirs reports
are unverified. This is important. Anyone can
submit something to Veirs. Anybody that there.
We can't glean anything from Veirs
Speaker 2: side effects and this vaccine,
any vaccine history and more deaths. Dr.
Robert Malone nine patents for the MRI
technology being used in the vaccines.
Speaker 1: Remember, Robert Malone's
claims have already been debunked.
Speaker 2: He came on my program weeks
ago and said, Unless you're over 65 and have a
comorbidity, I recommend it. Other than that,
I don't recommend taking it. He even is upset.
He took it himself. He's having heart issues.
Looking back, we know that warp speed was
great. You did amazing with getting it right
Speaker 1: and the talking out of both sides of
the mouth. The rapidity with which you got these
vaccines done is a. Amazing. We just don't
want them because they're not good vaccines.
Getting them is great using
them nuts. It's completely
I mean, it is a pretzel. It is a pretzel
Speaker 2: tape to get something out there.
But after now, so many months of the vaccine
being administered and these side effects
at Americans questions of it, do you reconsider
your push for it or what's your view now
on the vaccine in general?
Speaker 3: Well, I've taken it.
I've had the booster, many politicians. I
watched a couple of politicians be interviewed.
And one of the questions was, did you get the
booster because they had the vaccine and say,
Oh, they're answering it? Like, in other words,
the answer is yes, but they don't want to say it.
Speaker 1: He's very clearly referring to Ron
DeSantis there, and this is already a signal about
if DeSantis wants to be the nominee in 24
and Trump wants to be the nominee in 24. It's
going to get very ugly, very quickly, which I love
Speaker 3: because they're gutless. Got to say it,
whether he had it or not saying. But the fact
is that I think the vaccine has saved tens of
millions of people throughout the world. I've
had absolutely no side effects. I've had it, like
other people, have had it and nothing special.
Speaker 1: So Donald Trump, here is he. Other than
the fact that he takes credit for the vaccines for
which he deserves no credit, the US pre-purchase
doses, that's all they did. Trump deserves
no credit for the vaccine. These vaccines,
we're going to be developed in this amount of time
no matter who is president. You could have had,
you know, Barney rubble as president. These
vaccines would have been developed. Trump is
absolutely right about what he's saying, and it
is crazy that these networks now are having to
sort of play but put themselves in these pretzels.
Hilariously, this guy on OANN still equates Trump
to Jesus to just look at the level of sycophancy.
Speaker 2: Now, look, he's not perfect.
No one is he sins. I see, and we all sin. But as
you know, who did our savior, Jesus Christ hang
out with back in the day? Who did he use to spread
his message or do his will? Right? Guess what?
They weren't famous. They weren't politicians.
They weren't rulers or tyrants. They were lepers.
They were prostitutes. They were the blind and the
deformed. The people that society had cast away.
Yeah, they were, in a word, deplorables, right?
Speaker 1: So there we go. They still love Trump
and see him as a godlike figure.
When Trump is the voice of reason,
you know you're on an insane network. And I,
without any hesitation, Trump's lying about
his role in the vaccines. But what Trump is saying
about the vaccines themselves is absolutely right.